you decide what history is like we are
gonna decide how we are remembered and
the only way you decide that is you put
it down on paper first you tell now
there's no more paper right now there's
video right so it's like Jordan is gonna
go this is what happened with the Bulls
even if it isn't if you want to look
into the Bulls 30 years from now you're
gonna watch this documentary yeah and
this is history now and that's why
Isaiah Thomas so [ __ ] pissed because
I've been on some level he knows oh [ __ ]
I'm a dick throughout history oh [ __ ] so
he's trying to rectify that situation
and we go through this you know with our
stuff it's like you know if we see we
see history being shifted a little bit
in a way that we don't think is fair to
us and we need a corrective you know I
see I saw it happen with my parents
business my parts are completely we ran
out of like the dance business in the
way that and dance in general and now
they like you know support it it happens
you gotta fight for your place and I
think Jordan recognized that and he's
like I don't I don't have I don't care
about Scotty's version I don't think he
cares I grew to like I don't think he's
trying to make him look bad but like I'm
not I don't care that to explain your
[ __ ] this is about explaining why I'm
the greatest
I just think like if Scotty didn't give
him that much material of the show we
wouldn't see it well you know how much
drama there is on a [ __ ] team at all
times especially a dynasty this it but
it's like you don't see anything from
Kirk he said we see Rodman do you think
the only reason we're talking about Kerr
is because he has had a successful
coaching career yeah if Kerr wasn't the
coach to the Golden State Warriors he
wouldn't be in this documentary except
for when Jordan punched him in the face
yeah it'd be very small his role but
he's had this resurgence as a
broadcaster and as a coach and so now
since he's like a person of Fame we care
about him like Clyde Drexler was
probably as popular a player maybe as
Charles Barkley no no I don't think so
Charles he's had the personality choice
at present but like in terms of like he
was really good he was a sensational
dunker and he was like Clyde I mean it
was just it was an amazing guy he was
amazing player and they were six
right like but we don't remember Clyde
at all yeah because he didn't have this
second career as a sports commentator
which Charles had and he's so [ __ ]
entertaining I mean Kenny Smith Kenny
Smith will be remembered as a much
better basketball player than he was
because of his candy Smith is perfect
Charles even when he played had that
personality like the one the sons bull
series when they were up 3-1 the Bulls
and they were like boarding up yeah he
said any anything you'd like to say the
people of Chicago take this [ __ ] off the
windows like that's just a funny thing
to say as you're playing so I think he
got elevated while he was playing yeah
but to your point Kenny the jet Smith is
irrelevant because he had a post-playing
career Steve Kerr's in his documentary a
lot more because he had that now that
incident with Jordan punching him I
remember Jordan talking about that and
like one of the old shits yeah I'm like
the early 2000s or whatever some in the
chest he said he punched Cara punched me
the chance to Jordan punched her in the
face
what a weird weird place to punch
someone low skit it is kind of [ __ ]
right did you give him a [ __ ] purple
right half a foot taller than him oh yes
sir punch straight wing bro let's go you
go dance dance if you don't take a shot
it's like I respect think I respect most
about ti more than any rap song he's
ever dead or like I truly respect the
tea iced walnut Floyd right because you
got one shot you will get close enough
to swing it Floyd and if you drop them
you get to do the thing that no other
boxer has ever done yet yeah you a and
and he went for and he knew the security
was gonna separate in their brain could
knock out Floyd breath under percent
that's a real ass dude yeah Steve Kerr
out here Coleman Jordan's chest hairs
and [ __ ] of his walk out of here with
that and they're acting like I stood up
to him that changed our relationship no
didn't he punched the littlest guy on
the court and he felt bad for you I
don't think he had this this huge
respect for you afterwards I think he
felt bad I know I think Jordan needs to
know you have that in you trying to get
out of Burrell sir no you got a tacher
he's like okay I can go to war with this
guy I don't think he was like this is a
[ __ ] he's I can't believe he still I
think he's like okay good you got a
little something oh yeah you got
something in you listen do you think he
believes that like your [ __ ] gets
tight
if you don't stand up for yourself I
think he does so so in other words like
when the going gets tough people who
stand up for themselves are willing to
take the challenge yeah they'll go and
the people who aren't are going to get
nervous and they're gonna I think that's
his entire mentality he's trying to
maybe in his mind it's not I'm not being
mean I'm just gonna get you to that
point where you'll finally fight back
and then okay we're good
[Applause]